les etats unis font le bilan quotidien
des décès reparti à la hausse avec 1561
morts ces dernières 24 heures au total
on dénombre plus de 93 mille décès dans
le pays depuis le début de l'épidémie
et si le virus est en recul à new york
de nouveaux foyers sont apparus ailleurs
comme dans la région de washington où un
hôpital de campagne a été installé lundi
conséquence une fausse procession
funéraire a été organisé devant la
maison blanche par des manifestants qui
dénoncent la gestion de la crise par
donald trump plusieurs états pensent
déjà à rouvrir alors qu'on n'a même pas
fait le deuil
en tant que pays de tous les gens qui
ont déjà perdu la vie et donc je pense
que ce qu'on fait ici c'est qu'on crée
un espace on reconnaissait personne en
tant que victime du virus est victime de
l'inaction du président beaucoup de
familles différentes sont déjà impacté
par locaux vides et on sait que ce sont
les latinos les communautés noires qui
sont énormément impactés on veut
s'assurer que les précautions
appropriées soient prises et que le
président les prennent pour notre
communauté et pour tout le monde parce
qu'honnêtement tout le monde est
impactée en ce moment